[Musique]
elle les mouvements de bust les
créatures féminines de rachel bergerie
l'élu met 2 v le temps de l'exposition
le street art qui te la rue montrer aux
jeunes que ça s'expose que c'est un art
que c'est pas du duduk rhabillage que
c'est que ces jeunes gens comment dire
ils mettent toute leur âme et et toutes
leurs forces pour pour réaliser des
oeuvres dans ta forêt deuxième édition
met à l'honneur une dizaine d'artistes
issus des beaux-arts ou autodidacte aux
techniques variées travail à la bombe à
la peinture gravure et au graff
cette année ce sont des français sont
tous situés sur la région parisienne
même s'ils sont d'origine peuvent de
régionale provinciale
on en a une partie on va appeler les
locaux c'est le bande ku qui se situe à
lunebourg et tdf télédiffusion de france
qui est une friche industrielle s'était
transformé en atelier des talents
émergent sans limite si ce n'est celle
de la taille de leurs toiles
[Musique]